combien de paires de chaussures avez
vous dans votre placard
j'ai à peu près certaine ni su que vous
en avez moins que votre conjoint
mesdames 5 terre vapeur 60 perd 300 p il
semblerait que nous n'avons jamais la
bonne paire ou qui nous manque toujours
cette petite paire de stilettos pour
l'avicca rock noir et bien cette
relation particulière que nous avons
avec les chaussures dure presque toute
une vie mais surtout c'est qu'elle
débute très tôt
moi quand j'étais petite fille jade
auraient fouillé dans le placard de ma
mère pour enfiler ses plus jolis talons
ou son déclic à pic
j'avais l'impression de me transformer
en une grande dame j'étais vraiment bien
loin de me douter que plus tard ceci me
permettrai de d'élaborer un programme de
publier un livre hors de portée les
talents au est ce effectivement ma
passion pour le mouvement at avant mes
30 années de danse de nier mais de
marionnettes qui me permet aujourd'hui
d'accompagner les femmes d'un délit
femmes des hommes aussi je vais vous
dire franchement à retrouver contact
avec leur pouvoir féminin leur confiance
en soi à travers cet objet révélateur
qui est le talon tout au long des
recherches j'étais quand même très
surprise de constater à quel point tout
au lond c'est nos ressources de son
évolution le tableau a été fidèle témoin
de son temps
si le talon puis ses origines au
proche-orient du 9ème siècle alors que
les cavaliers porter des bottes à talons
afin de mieux tenir sur leurs étriers
c'est un tout petit bout de femme de 15
ans que nous devons le talon haut comme
accessoire de mode afin de rivaliser
avec un magnifique diane de poitiers qui
était à l'époque la maîtresse de son
futur époux
catherine de médicis demande à son beau
tic bélie fier de les conforter une
bottine
à talons afin de pouvoir avoir un peu
plus de panache le jour de son mariage
avec le futur roi de france
elle fit absolument sensation le talon
haut fut adoptée par toutes les cours
d'europe
il devient un signe distinctif de
l'aristocratie
à ce titre il fut longtemps porté par
les hommes autant que par les femmes ou
les enfants il évolua au cours de
l'histoire au cours des modes des
caprices des rois et de la dextérité de
leurs artisans
faut quand même se rappeler que tout au
long de son évolution
à l'instant où le talon était associé
identifié avec le pouvoir économique où
le pouvoir social ou à la fonctionnalité
il était nécessairement associée avec la
domination masculine
a contrario lorsqu'il est à identifier
avec la frivolité ou l'ineptie ou encore
qu'ils présentaient des valeurs érotique
il était associé avec la féminité
ainsi sous l'influencé des philosophes
du siècle des lumières
alors que la femme fut catalogué comme
un être irrationnel et par votre
conséquence inapte à devenir citoyenne à
part entière
le talent au pub abandonnés par les
hommes il perdit son symbole
emblématique d'objets de pouvoir pour
devenir enfant un extrait soir
exclusivement féminin il n'en faudra pas
plus pour que le talon soit récupéré par
les artistes à travers la gravure et la
peinture érotique en 1863 edouard manet
fut le premier peintre a illustré une
femme toute nue talons aux pieds
sa fameuse olympien mais ce sont surtout
les pornographes de la fin du 19e siècle
qui profitèrent de l'avancée technique
de la photographie en syrie pour
érotiser le talent au leurs petites
cartes postales en noir et blanc où
figuraient leurs modèles nus talons aux
pieds circulait secrètement sous les
manteaux et éveillait bien des désirs
femme nudité talent ou la chaussure se
chargent d'érotisme et devient puis
un symbole sexuel alors qu'est ce qui
fait que ce petit objet peut être
qualifié ainsi d'objet sexuel mais faut
d'abord comprendre que la chaussure a
dit ou plutôt diaby le pied qui de tout
le corps féminin est la partie la plus
érotique des moyens dont en amérique
bien sûr que non le pis c'est quelque
chose de moche ça des verrues décor des
oignons des pieds d'athlètes
mais partout ailleurs depuis plus de dix
mille ans le pied est hautement érotisée
alors ce pied cette chaussure recouvre
donc ce pied hélas souvent le bout
pointu ou du moins - roncq look look
plus pointu que rond elle a une coupe
fine et collante sensuelle qui colle à
la peau elle est souvent ornementé de
bouc 202 rue bande de croire et dans
tous les cas elle a un talent au et plus
le temps long et aux mulets chargés
d'érotisme
il faut savoir que de tous les
fétichisme sexuel celui du talon et du
pied sont encore aujourd'hui les plus
pratiques et puis j'aime raison pour
laquelle le talon est un symbole sexuel
c'est pour les effets qu'ils provoquent
il provoque deux types d'effets les
effets psychologiques et des effets
physiologiques
il lui manquait ce qui se passe il
modifie le corps de la femme en
accentuant ses attributs féminins tout
en les érotisant le pied dans un talon
paraître plus petit et cambrai alors ce
pied encore ici on le veut petit et
cambrai pourquoi depuis dix mille ans
sociétés occidentales sociétés
orientales sophistiquées aux primitifs
le petit pied et valoriser même docteur
alfred kinsey d'en-face dans ce livre
cherche des années 50 avait découvert
que pendant l'orgasme
vous marquez à s'asseoir mesdames
messieurs
pendant l'orgasme nash en point et que
les pieds comme une ballerine alors le
pied dans un panneau nous rappellerait
cette image de pied en pleine extase
qu'est-ce qui fait d'autres canaux il
affine la cheville il allonge la jambe
il fait rebondir les fessiers il
projette la poitrine vers l'avant quand
on en a il accentue la courbe des reins
et il favorise le balancement du bassin
ce qui ne manque pas de titiller
l'imaginaire masculin mais joue aussi
des drôles de choses de talent c'est à
dire qu'il dérange la verticalité
naturelles du corps en projetant le
poids de la porteuse vers l'avant il
dérange donc cette verticalité
il dérange la marche elissa câble pas et
le raccourci et il est la cause de mille
et un douleur et malgré tous les
avertissements du corps médical pour
nous faire arrêter de porter des talons
des dangers des blessures des mots et
c'est franchement mes dents allons-nous
redescendre sur le plancher des vaches
deuxième type d'effet les effets
psychologiques
ils sont très différents si nous sommes
la personne qui porte parole de talons
ou la personne connectée - mesdames
lorsque vous enfilez vos cadeaux est-ce
que vous ressentez quelque chose de
particulier il ya des femmes qui disent
je me sens plus féminine je me sens plus
sexy mais toutes les femmes de mon
entourage surtout les centaines de
femmes accusent d'informations sont à
peu près tous d'accord pour dire que dès
l'instant où elles ont fait leurs
chaussures elles font une espèce
d'énergie monter en elle une espèce de
pouvoir une espèce de confiance qui se
développe et que cette confiance pour
aller se traduit une romance ou de vente
d'assurances et consciemment ou non
cette assurance
elles vont le puiser au plus profond de
leur énergie féminine
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
peu de femmes achètent porte des talons
dans le but de séduire ou de réveiller
votre libido messieurs
les femmes achètent leurs talons souvent
sur des coups de coeur selon leur humeur
en forme de compensation ou de
récompense mais elle les porte
principalement pour elle-même pour le
pouvoir qui leur donne côté masculin
c'est toute notre histoire même si à
quelques-uns d'entre vous qui avoue ne
pas être intéressés du tout par les
talons c'est quand même le plupart des
hommes avouent finalement que le talon
donc rêver quelque chose chez eux 2-1
c'est à dire qu'en plus de les
modifications son apparence qu'ils
apprécient c'est aussi cette nouvelle
illusion à parent de fragilité et de
vulnérabilité de la porteuse ou
complètement le contraire
cette assurance marquez qui agissent
comme stimulant et pratiques etc dans le
cas des pratiques sexuelles ou le talent
on prend tout son ambivalence parce que
pour l'homme qui sensibles au talon il
te réveiller soit son côté de domination
ou soit son côté de soumission
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui fait dire à
certaines féministes de talent serre a
finalement assouvir les fantasmes
masculins et à objectiver la femme mais
elles ont pas tout à fait tort parce que
si le talon était réservé à la stricte
intimité des rapports amoureux
le problème c'est complètement différent
mais puisque l'état ne fait partie
intégrante de la vie des femmes et
qu'elles ne font autant dans le cas de
leur vie personnelle que dans le cas de
leur vie professionnelle
le danger survient à partir du moment où
le message qu'elle souhaite transmettre
et mal compris ou l'image qu'elle dégage
et mal interprétés le phénomène est
d'autant plus criant finalement que nous
assistons depuis quelques années au
phénomène damas dévastateur de
l'hypersexualisation
qui est vraiment un véhiculé par la mode
et les médias les designers ont autre
âge eusement sexualisé leurs créations
en empruntant les codes issus de la
pornographie et en banalisant bien des
formes des fétichismes il est parfois
vraiment difficile de savoir si des
chaussures en boutique vend à qui elles
sont destinées
il faut savoir quand même que l'état
nous ont une personnalité qui leur est
propre et parfois très très très forte
et ce type de choses on ne peuvent pas
être porté par n'importe qui et dans
n'importe quelle circonstance
mais pourquoi d'une part à cause de la
charge émotive qu'elles ont mais aussi
en raison de la difficulté de bouger
avec ce genre de chaussures je suis
certain que certains d'entre vous peut
être même tout le monde a été témoin au
moins deux fois dans son envie de voir
une femme tituber difficilement ou
marcher comme ça au marché que mon bref
beaucoup de difficultés à marcher en
talons et c'est pas toujours heureux et
là je vous illustrez donc cet exemple là
parce que viviane wade foot qui est une
des z'ailleurs britannique des années 70
ce qui a vraiment été très bonne pour
nous donner nous nous choquer finalement
elle a voulu transcender ce type de
talons hauts
rigide lourde qui empêche la mobilité
qui réduit la la marche
elle avoue donc transcender cette poule
a et suffit un véritable pouvoir de
domination à celle qui les porterait
alors elle a demandé à naomi campbell
qui était à l'époque la reine des
podiums se présenter sa collection
elle n'a pas fait dit pas avant de
tomber
ces exemples sont un peu extrême mais
n'en demeure pas moins qu'au quotidien
la maladresse et le manque d'assurance
en talons hauts facilement associer à la
vulnérabilité voire même à la soumission
parce que le talent on peut prendre deux
angles différents
il peut être un objet de soumission ou
un objet de pouvoir
la différence va se faire simplement
dans la façon du choix du show sûr qu'on
va faire mais aussi et surtout à la
manière dont elle sera portée
alors afin d'éviter vraiment tout
malentendu
moi je vais vous donner les trois quais
connaître la signification des codes du
tableau et de sa représentation dans
l'imaginaire collectif afin de pouvoir
choisir adéquatement le type de
chaussures que nous allons porter en
fonction de notre âge notre morphologie
du contexte et des circonstances
développer ses compétences en tant que
porteuse en apprenant les techniques du
port de talons et ça s'apprend à travers
un travail sur la posture la démarche
l'attitude et la lure afin d'afficher
une assurance gracieuse mais agile
maîtrise et l'étendue de son vocabulaire
corporels afin finalement de communiquer
de façon claire et convaincante le
message que l'on choisit de trentenaires
parce que sans ce travail de prise de
conscience et sans ce travail sur soi on
laisse le champ ouvert à toute critique
il surtout à toute personne qui continue
de croire qu'une femme en talons hauts
est un être irrationnel disponibles
sexuellement ou que sa valeur nette
égale qu'à sa capacité à susciter le
désir
le canot est un formidable et précieux
outil de communication une ponctuent
modules et affine finalement les
relations entre individus
ils influencent les rapports que nous
avons avec les hommes et les femmes mais
parce qu'ils y si étroitement associées
à la séduction à la sexualité et au jour
de la pornographie
il est essentiel de pouvoir décider de
la représentation que nous souhaitons
donner de nous mêmes parce que le talent
n'a de sens que si nous permet
d'affirmer notre identité et d'exprimer
fidèlement qui nous sommes
je crois sincèrement que le talent au
est en train de devenir
un symbole d'affirmation d'une timidité
nouvelle revendiquant des valeurs plus
humanistes les plus universels et comme
bien des femmes
on choisit souvent de porter des talons
déjà pour renverser une autre rôle de
subalterne pour renforcer notre
confiance pour même affirmer notre
autorité avancer dans nos carrières
la femme actuelle la femme de la
renaissance au cas n'a pas besoin de
talons hauts pour s'affirmer au pour
vivre sa féminité
mais moi je suis convaincu que si nous
devons choisir de porter des canaux on
devrait choisir de saisir le pouvoir
original et emblématique qu'est la
petite catherine de médicis a fait
naître ya plus de 400 ans alors symbole
sexuel paradoxal ou contradictoires
attributs féminins accessoires de mode
le talent aux objets de soumission objet
de pouvoir c'est à chacun de vous de
décider
merci